thank you for attending my presentation
on homomorphic encryption with microsoft
seal
my name is kim line i'm a researcher at
microsoft research
in washington
to motivate this talk i want to start by
explaining something about cloud
computation today
if you think of a scenario where there's
a cloud such as azure
and a user a customer
and they want to engage in some kind of
cloud computation
service well there's a privacy barrier
between these two
uh meaning that the customer doesn't
just want to share
all of their data with the cloud service
provider this is normal and
natural well how do you get around this
you or the customer takes their files
uses a secret key uses some standard
pharmacy
of encryption encrypts the files
sends them over to the cloud
and the cloud can now store them but
what happens if the cloud wants to
actually perform some kind of
computation on this this is very typical
well the user the customer has to share
their key
with the cloud so that the cloud can
remove the encryption
then do a computation
use the key to encrypt the result again
and send the encrypted result back
where the customer can decrypt it and
obtain the result this is how it's done
today
the cloud does the decryption and the
re-encryption of the result very quickly
and the key is access controlled
so hopefully there is no malicious
operator there or
any hacker actually getting access to
the data
but this is obviously a weak spot here
the data is exposed
to potentially malicious operators
or other such parties
in fact we often talk about three stages
of data privacy
the simplest is data
data privacy in transit where we can use
techniques such
as tls to secure data this is what you
do all the time when you
interact with all kinds of cloud
services
websites and like
when you use cloud storage you need
always encryption at rest
this is very standard typically
something like aes
encryption is used
but the third one is privacy
during computation and in fact there is
no standard way of achieving this
and in reality what i just showed you on
the previous slide
is what is being done
homomorphic encryption is what can give
us this
third stage of data privacy
homomorphic encryption is a relatively
new kind of encryption technology
that allows you to compute directly on
encrypted data
this means that the result remains
encrypted
and only the data owner who has the
secret key
can read the result this means that
we can get end-to-end encryption in
these kinds of cloud computation
scenarios
so let's take a look at this again
with homomorphic encryption we again
have our privacy barrier here
but now this customer encrypts their
data
sends the encrypted data over and
because
we're using homomorphic encryption now
the cloud can simply compute on the
encrypted data
so there is nothing like key sharing
here
the customer always keeps the key the
data is sent back the encrypted
result is sent back where
the client can remove the customer can
remove the encryption
and obtain the result
now to be perfectly clear homomorphic
encryption is a very new type of
encryption it's not like aes
it's not like rsa it's something else
and in these kinds of systems there is
no hidden decryption happening
so data enters changes and leaves the
untrusted network
the cloud always in encrypted form
and whatever data is leaked or revealed
is always done by the client the
customer
they are the ones who are able to
decrypt results and then share those
results
so so the cloud can't do anything like
sell the customers data now
microsoft has some significant assets in
homomorphic encryption in fact our group
has been working on this
for many years now and we have a
software library called microsoft seal
that we have been developing since 2015
this is being actively developed today
and
it's been released under an open source
license last year
you can download the source code from
github.com microsoft
seal and start playing with it yourself
in fact it works on all of the major
platforms windows linux and mac os
and it just requires a basic
c plus compiler steel also has
c-sharp wrappers so you can use it from
your.net core applications
now nothing comes for free and
homomorphic encryption
has some amazing functionality and this
kind of property does certainly not come
for free
or for cheap in fact a lot of people
have heard of homomorphic encryption
before
and most likely they've heard that it's
very slow and very complicated
and that probably was true when they
heard it
but if you look at this graph here
where we have performance overhead on
the y-axis
and the year on the x-axis you see that
we have made some amazing progress
within the past few years
in fact the y-axis here is a logarithmic
scale
and you can see that indeed when in 2019
when this technology was invented
the performance overhead was 12 orders
of magnitude which is
extremely huge but in 2015 already
we've come down to something like five
orders of magnitude
going forward to 2019 we're at about
four orders of magnitude
and today we're looking at techniques
such as gpu acceleration
fpg acceleration and finally
hopefully asics in speeding this
technology up and we're expecting to get
more than two orders of magnitude
performance improvement from these kinds
of
technologies
what does this mean this means that that
this this homomorphic encryption is in
fact very ripe for adoption
and to prove that let me tell you of an
experiment that we did
you know seeing all those performance
numbers
seeing uh some examples some
code examples that only tells you so
much
but can we actually build
some real world applications with this
stuff
what about the fitness tracker a fitness
tracker is
an interesting application it collects
some
very private information namely it
collects location information it
collects
potentially health care information
medical information such as heart rate
it can use information such as your
age your height your weight
and how does it use this it collect it
computes
statistics on your location on your run
data
on your health data it can give you
classifications it can give you
predictions of
of your or related to your exercise
it can recommend better
exercise routines for you
well what is the privacy problem the
privacy problem is that
most of these applications store the
data in a cloud service
of course because you don't want to
store such information on your phone you
don't have
that much memory there
obviously there is a privacy problem and
this is what we said to tackle
we implemented this using microsoft seal
we created a private fitness tracker
tracker called azure run
it encrypts your location data and it
stores the encrypted data in azure
it classifies your run intensity but it
does the computation on the encrypted
data
it computes summary statistics of your
run of the distance time
but it does those computations all on
encrypted data in the cloud
this means that there's no need to
download the raw run data back to the
device
so it's just like any normal fitness
tracker but
your privacy is preserved in fact we
very recently released this code this
app
and you can you can download the source
code from github.com as microsoft slash
seal demo and you can
see for yourself how it works
here's an example of the app running
this is
running on an android emulator on the
left hand side and on the right hand
side
we see azure's view of the app so this
is the database
well what are we seeing here on the left
hand side the app is running it's
actually simulating some run
and for all practical purposes
it's a running app you don't see
there's nothing obvious that the user
would see there that would make them
think that okay this is an encrypted
encrypted running app but this is
exactly the point
it uses this powerful technology under
the hood
you get extremely strong privacy
guarantees your location is not shared
with the cloud
your information is not shared with the
cloud but you still get the service and
it works fine
on the right hand side we can indeed see
that azure only sees garbage data or
encrypted data for the location for the
time
for the run route and the statistics
we can see that once this run completed
a new entry was added to the database
so now you want to try microsoft sale
how do you get it you go to github you
you clone and uh you download it
and you build it like i already
mentioned before
silly speed and c plus plus 17 so you
can use it on any
platform that has a c plus compiler
it's actually also possible to compile
cl as c plus
14 if for some reason you don't have a c
plus 17 compiler available
in addition the code has a folder called
net with the.net standard wrappers that
make it very easy to build azure
services with seal
and if you look at the source code
you will see that there are multiple
examples
very well commented examples available
in both languages
this is certainly the best way to learn
seal
you should go over those examples look
at the code and run them
and see read those comments and
and see how it works
so what does seal do you can do
encryption and decryption of course it
uses homomorphic encryption here again
this is not like aes this is a very
special kind of encryption you have to
use
seal for encrypting you can't use seal
just for computing on encrypted data you
have to also encrypt the data with seal
it is a low level library and
in that sense it doesn't provide you
high level statistics
functionality for example or anything
like that
anything like linear algebra on top of
encrypted data it provides you low level
primitives
addition subtraction and multiplication
of encrypted numbers
in fact c allows you to encrypt vectors
of numbers at a time
you don't just encrypt one number you
typically would encrypt thousands of
numbers at a time
and in addition to computing on these
vectors
with addition and subtraction
multiplication you can also rotate them
in encrypted form
still comes with the functionality for
serialization
so you can easily serialize your cipher
text
your plain texts your encryption
parameters
and various other seal objects
like already mentioned there are many
well commented examples that you should
go over
now once you start looking at those
examples you will see
two abbreviations mentioned bfb
and ckks these are two encryption
schemes that seal support
the bfe scheme is meant for
performing encrypted modular arithmetic
so you encrypt
integers modulo some prime number
and then you compute on those integers
module of that prime number
this is good for exact computations you
if you want to perform exact integer
computations
you need to choose a big enough prime
number so you don't get data type
overflow
this is just like in classical
programming where
you might have a 32-bit data type or
64-bit data type
you need to watch out for overflow
the cks scheme is very different it
allows you to compute
on real or complex numbers so you
encrypt
a vector of real or complex numbers and
then you can perform these
additions and multiplications on that
dkks is very good for approximate
computations
of course in real numbers in floating
point numbers you never have
exact arithmetic you always have
approximate arithmetic and this is what
you have also in the cks key
for example if you want to evaluate the
machine learning model on encrypted data
the cks scheme is probably the right
choice
because you don't need an exactly
correct exact
or exactly correct result just need an
approximately correct result
but it's much more performant than the
bfs game
so let's look at a simple code example
that demonstrates some very basic
functionality in seal
setting up the bfe scheme and doing
additions and multiplications
so in this case i have two
cpp files one for you know client
and one for the cloud server
in a typical scenario we can imagine
that the client wants to encrypt some
data
maybe it is some health data
it wants to encrypt that it wants to
send that over to the server
and it wants the server to perform some
kind of computation on it
for example evaluating uh
some predictive model maybe giving some
health related prediction but the client
is concerned about their privacy so
that's why they want to use homomorphic
encryption and the server obviously
does not want to share their model with
the client because it's their
proprietary model
so what do we do the client
sets up an object called encryption
parameters
and specifies that they want to use
scheme type
bfv they need to set
a few encryption parameters namely the
poly modulus degree
which we set to 8192 why do we set it to
this
well it's explained in quite some detail
in the examples that come with seal
basically the bigger this polymodulus
degree is
the more encrypted computation you can
do
if polymodulus degree is very small you
can only do
one multiplication if polymodules degree
is very large
then you can do much more but it's going
to be slower
now once we have set the polymodulus
degree we set the second parameter
called coeff modulus this one
is set to some default value based on
the polymodulus degree that we just set
finally in the bfe scheme we set the
plane modulus
to be 2 to the 20 in this example
why well the plane modulus measures
the size of your plaintext data type
like i said earlier
the bfe scheme computes an integers
module or some
number and in this case the number the
modulus
is 2 to the 20.
now the next step
is to create something called the seal
context
the seal context is created after
setting the encryption parameters
and it basically validates that the
parameters are set correctly
and it performs some pre-computations
on those parameters so it's important
that your seal context
stays alive throughout the use of of
seal
because all of your pre-computations are
going to be there
after creating the seal context we're
ready to do some
encryption but to do that we we need to
set up our keys our public and our
secret key so
microsoft seal provides public key
encryption schemes
both bfv and ckks are public key
which means that there's a separate key
for encryption
the public key and for decryption the
secret key
so anyone who has the public key can
encrypt
but only if you have the secret key you
can decrypt
now all we need to do is create the key
generator we give it the context
and we can read off the public key
and the secret key from that
great let's encrypt some numbers
to encrypt integers with the bfe scheme
i need to create an integer encoder
class
or integer encoder object
again integer encoder constructor takes
the context
as a parameter as does basically every
other
steel object also the context has to
stay alive
throughout the use of this library
create a plain text pt1 by
encoding the number five and we create
the plaintext pd2
by encoding the number seven
note that at this point we haven't done
any encryption yet
this is just encoding this the integer
encoder gives you plain text objects
it converts integers to plain text
objects if you use cks
there is a ckks encoder class
that converts vectors of real or complex
numbers
into plain text objects once you have
the plain text
you can encrypt them with the encryptor
object so we create an encrypter
and we need to give the encryptor the
public key
again because this is public key
encryption encryption uses the public
key
decryption uses the secret key
and what we do here we create
ciphertext ct1 and ct2
and we do encrypter.encrypt pt1 comma
cd1 so this encrypts pt1
writes that to ct1 and we do the same
for
pt2 and ct2
now once we're done with encryption
this is now our private medical data we
can save the encryption parameters to a
stream
and we can save our cipher text also to
the stream
and now we send this over somehow to the
cloud
to the server
and now let's imagine that the server
has received this data
and the server has a stream that it can
read
read from of course to get started on
the server side
we need to set up encryption parameters
and we need to create the sealed context
so what do we do
we deserialize the encryption parameters
from the stream and then we create a
sealed context object
great
next we want to read the cipher text
from our stream
so we do ciphertext ct1ct2 ct1.load
and we need to give it the context and
we need to give it the stream
and same for cd2 now we have the two
ciphertexts
next we want to do the magical part
which is the computation on encrypted
data
how do we do that we need an evaluator
class
and we simply call evaluator.addct1ct2
and we write the result to ct sum a
third ciphertext
we do the same for multiply
evaluate that multiply c d one c two and
we write
the result the c d prod and now if
everything has worked correctly
ct sum will be the encryption of five
plus seven
and c d prime will be the encryption of
five times seven
so what we can do well what does the
server do at this point
it saves the result it sends it over to
the client
and the client can decrypt and obtain
the result
of course the client receives the the
sum and the product and
it can then uh well it has to
deserialize them from some
from some stream it seems like i have a
typo there
it should be ctsum.loadcontext.comstream
ctsum ctprod.load context
comma stream so we load both the
sum and the product from the from a
stream
to decrypt uh we need to create a
decrypter object
and in this case we need the secret key
so this is
the magical thing that only the client
can do the server does not have the
secret key
and therefore the server can never set
up the decrypter
and we have a we create a plain text for
the sum
and for the product and we call
decrypter.decrypt
ct sum comma pt sum and same for
ct prod and pt prod
now this pt sum and pt prod are still
plain text objects
we want to obtain an integer result from
them
because that's what we're interested in
we create an int sum in prod
and we use encoder.d code in 32
and we can obtain these results
and if you compile this code it will
give you the correct result for the sum
and the product of
five and seven of course this is a
an extremely simple example just
demonstrating
the most basic functionality of seal in
reality
in most practical applications you would
want to
use some technique called batching where
you can encrypt entire vectors at a time
you can operate on entire vectors of
numbers
at a time this gives a huge performance
improvement
and is typically the basis of any
highly performant application of
homomorphic encryption
but if you look at the examples that
come with the code you will see this
batching functionality demonstrated
along with many other
techniques
if you want very advanced examples you
can look at github.com
microsoft see a demo this is where our
running up
our azure run code is but there's also
other examples there
for example showing some matrix
arithmetic on encrypted matrices
that's the end of my presentation
and we're ready to take some questions
now
any questions
hi everyone
thank you for attending the webinar so
i'm going to now
take some time to answer questions that
you sent
first question that we got this how
secure is homomorphic encryption
well um you could um
equally well ask like how secure is any
encryption
how do researchers know this well it's
mostly
based on our best best research
so mathematicians and computer
scientists have looked at the hard
problems that
different encryption schemes are based
on and
estimated that it takes this and this
much time to break
some form of encryption such as rsa
encryption or
elliptic curve encryption just like that
for homomorphic encryption
we have studied those hard problems that
are underlying the
scheme as far as the researchers know
the mathematicians it is very hard to
break homomorphic encryption
in fact we don't even know
how to do it with quantum computers so
in fact we say that homomorphic
encryption is a
post-quantum encryption scheme in that
sense
now as you saw in the webinar
it is homomorphic encryption contains
all these different parameters like
polymodulus degree coeff modulus
and it's important that these are set
correctly
to get a secure instantiation of the
encryption but seal will actually
help you in doing this so seal will make
it so that
well seal will actually prevent you from
setting those parameters in securely
next question is um what is the best
source of documentation for the c
library currently i would say that the
best source of documentation by far
is the code samples that come come with
the library
so if you clone it from github
you will see that there is this examples
folder
both for c plus and for c sharp
and it contains basically
several examples that are very very
much commented and there's a lot of
explanation of those different
encryption parameters
of different conceptual things related
to homomorphic encryption
but these different encoders are that
were briefly discussed in the webinar
and what the different encryption
schemes are there's also some
performance test
examples that come with the code so
these are both for c
plus and dot net and those examples are
basically
similar to each other
we have also created a few videos on
youtube about installation of seal
for linux mac os and windows
and in the future we're hoping to create
more videos especially
we're hoping to create videos describing
more conceptual things about homomorphic
encryption
such as how the zkks scheme works which
we've seen
is quite a complicated thing to learn
next question is what is the recommended
way to use this on blockchain slash
distributed ledger technology framework
to make it gdpr compliant
well i'm not i'm not a lawyer but
as far as i understand gdpr and other
other such privacy laws are very much
focused on intent
rather than the specific technology that
is being used
so as long as you can
convince convinced lawyers that
this encryption is secure as secure as
any other
standard encryption then i would
imagine that that would be enough but of
course
i don't really i don't really know the
full details of these kinds of
topics another question that is
related would be how can we make this
hipaa compliant
again hipaa is very much intent focused
so if you can make the case that
this encryption is
sound and valid and standard then then i
don't see any
uh other obstruction there
next question is i am a data scientist
and use
python in my work can i use steel from
python
currently as came up in the webinar we
only have
z plus plus and c-sharp apis for seal
it would be possible and it would be
nice to create a python
api or python wrappers for seal
but it's quite a lot of work to maintain
those which is why we haven't done it
yet
if someone wants to do this of course
that would be very greatly appreciated
actually there is an open source project
called by seal
but this is not by microsoft and
at least some time ago it wasn't
maintained very much
but uh this is certainly something that
one could uh one could do and it might
be a valuable contribution
if someone is interested in doing that
also uh of course because steel is open
source it's possible that
someone would create such uh python
wrappers and then contribute them to
seal itself
and if anyone is interested in doing
this uh please just let us know and
we might be happy to help
next question is is seal available in
azure
well it's
because seal is open source it's like a
low level system library
you can download it and install it on
any machine or any
virtual machine now
one challenge is that it's not
necessarily easy to build applications
from seal
so you would still need some developer
who's fairly familiar with encryption
and and has put a lot of effort into
learning
homomorphic encryption to create some
services that you would be running
in azure or aws aws or any
any cloud system
it's possible that in the future
microsoft will develop
services higher level services based on
steel and then that
those would be available in azure but
currently
see this like a standalone standalone
project
and download it then you can use it as
much as you want
it seems that
more questions so next um
he's still subject to malleability
attacks
well this is a great question
homomorphic encryption is inherently
malleable
so what does what this means is that
if i encrypt some data and i send it
over to my friend
someone can intercept this data before
my friend gets it
and basically just do some computation
on it to change it and now my
friend gets the data and uh maybe my
friend is decrypting it or something
but now they get the wrong result
because someone modified it along the
way
seal is definitely vulnerable to this
however the problem is that
or the solution really is that you have
to sign your messages before you send
them
so you need to use some standard
signature scheme
this is very typical like almost always
when you communicate encrypted data
you would want also to be assigned
and those uh that kind of signature
system might then require also some
public key infrastructure like
well actually maybe to get all of this
you you might want to communicate seal
cypher
ciphertext through the ls or a similar
channel
next question if i use seal just for
adding two ciphertext would it be faster
than uh
varsity homomorphic schemes such as the
payers key
well in many applications actually you
only want to do addition you don't
necessarily care about multiplication
this is for example you can imagine that
there's a big database
and you want to sum up with an encrypted
database all the values are encrypted
and you just want to sum up
some or all of them in encrypted form
so of course this doesn't really require
the fully homomorphic encryption such as
seal wear
where you can also do multiplications
you only need to do additions
in this case though i would still say
that seal is probably going to be faster
than
than schemes like fire that are
that are using some other primitives
it's because well one reason is that
seal uses
this still can enable this thing called
batching
where you can ena where you can encrypt
vectors at a time
and you can do very high dimensional
vector operations at the time
so if you need to aggregate a lot of
numbers together you can actually
encrypt them into vectors and then you
can just add those vectors together and
now you can do
like thousands of additions at the same
time it's almost certainly going to be
faster than
than singly homomorphic encryption
schemes
so here's a good question is there a way
to perform a search operation at the
cloud to retrieve specific records
this is definitely possible in some
sense
so you have to understand though that
a search if you if you want to do a
search
within say encrypted keyword but suppose
there's some
list of values and you want to know if
your specific value is in that list
you have to go through the list
like you have to do like a linear search
through the list and the reason is that
the reason is that on encrypted data you
can't have any branching
otherwise it would leak information
about the search term
which is supposed to be encrypted but we
have done such
such things in some sense for example we
have two papers
on something called private set
intersection where the idea is that i
have a set
and then another party has a set of
items
and we want to find which items we have
in common without revealing
our items to each other and the
protocols that we have created
they encrypt a smaller one of the two
sets
since that encrypted set the other side
who then computes that
matching on encrypted data
they get an encrypted intersection which
they can send back
and the first party can decrypt the
result and can
see which items the two sets had in
common
so this is this is certainly possible to
do
here's a good very important question
how do you know what parameters to
choose for security
like i mentioned feel
actually um enforces secure parameters
today
this is because we had so many people
use it and set it up
insecurely that we just decided to
to enforce it so that if you um
if you create your encryption parameters
and you set them and you create your
sealed context
if your encryption parameters were not
secure it's simply going to throw an
exception
and say that the parameters are invalid
now like again how do we know that these
parameters are secure it's
it's based on the best known research
and we have a standardization effort for
homomorphic encryption
called homomorphic encryption.org so if
you go to that website
you see that the group of researchers
came together and we brought this
so-called security standard for
homomorphic encryption
where we took a look at all of the best
known attacks
we evaluated them and we studied them a
lot
and we created these tables
that basically tell us or they can kind
of
help developers know how to set those
parameters in a secure way and this is
what
this is what seal uses to determine
whether or not the parameters you set
are
are secure
well what is the best source of
documentation other than the example
code
we used to have this pdf document called
the field manual
but it hasn't been updated in a long
time
i'm not sure if
we're going to pick that up again but
if you need help with some specific
technical issues
there's a stack overflow tag seal
so you can post questions there and
many of us would be happy to answer
those and maybe other civ users also
would be happy to answer so maybe that's
a good good source of help
if you have specific technical questions
if you have some
very complex questions or for some
reason you don't want to ask them on
stack overflow
you can just email us at sealcrypto
microsoft.com i'm sure
some of us will be very happy to uh
happy to help and respond
question for unlimited number of
operations on encrypted data
bootstrapping is needed there are plan
to add bootstrapping
indeed homomorphic encryption and the
way it is implemented in seal
it only allows you to do a limited
number of computations
limited number of operations so
depending on how big you
how big you choose your parameters the
more operations you can do
but then it becomes slower and in this
sense if you want to do a very complex
computation
then you would need absolutely huge
parameters
and it would become really really slow
and basically it wouldn't make sense
now bootstrapping is
an operation that
allows you to sort of
sort of refresh your
your ciphertext in some sense because
what happens here is
when you compute on ciphertext they
become more and more
corrupted until at the end they're so
corrupted that they just
don't you can't even decrypt them
anymore this is why you need bigger
parameters so you get more of this
this room for the error and then you
have
then you can do more computation until
the ciphertext is corrupted
and bootstrapping is an operation that
in some sense refreshes that
corruption so
now this is why you would want to have
bootstrapping because it allows you to
refresh whenever you're ciphered again
ciphertext gets very corrupted you can
refresh it and you can keep on computing
and now that the question was are we
planning on adding bootstrapping to seal
and the answer to this is yes
in fact bootstrapping for the cks scheme
will be available in seal
hopefully in the next major release
definitely in the next major release but
this is only for the cks ckks
for the bfb scheme it is not so easy to
see that bootstrapping would be useful
and uh the implementation challenges in
that are
like quite different this is why we're
not considering
bfe bootstrapping
so here's a good question can we compare
two encrypted numbers
if no can still be coupled with
cardboard circuits
for doing this
what is your recommendation for a kerbal
circuit tool okay so
on encrypted data it is difficult i
would say to compare
to encrypted numbers like with the cks
scheme
it is possible to do some kind of
approximate comparison
but an exact comparison is not possible
with ckks with bfb exact comparison
of integers is in principle possible
but in practice it's it's so
inefficient that it doesn't necessarily
it probably doesn't make sense
however what is possible and kind of
already came up in one of the earlier
questions was
equality testing so if you if you have
two encrypted numbers
encrypted with the bfe it is possible to
do some kind of exact matching exam
equality test of these two that kind of
thing is
more feasible but
then there was this question if no can
still be coupled with carbol circuits
and indeed it can be coupled with
garbled circuits for example
if you look at our our paper on
on the private set intersection
paper called again
so we have two papers regarding private
set intersection both published at ccs
the latter one was from last year tcs
and if you look at that paper you will
see that
we in fact mention that after the
private set intersection computation on
using homomorphic encryption
it is possible to continue with some
kind of
secure computation mpc protocol
to sort of like enhance that
functionality you could get
psi uh
plus you know aggregation or any other
kind of computation with
uh with that on that intersection
and the benefit of that protocol was
that the communication size is still
always proportional to the smaller set
not to the larger set
okay is it um can you shed some light on
the mathematics
behind homomorphic encryption
sure so most homomorphic encryption
schemes today
depend on a hard problem called
ring learning with errors this is
this is basically a variant of another
problem called
called learning with errors the thing
about the ring learning with errors is
that it results in slightly more
efficient
homomorphic encryption schemes and today
indeed like i said
almost all homomorphic encryption
schemes use ring learning with errors as
the
kind of heart underlying heart problem
and what kind of problem is this ring
learning with error as well
it is in fact typically when you when
you start learning about it
it's framed as some kind of
often people say that is some kind of
hard lattice problem and
it is indeed it is but the
the most simple representation of string
learning with errors involves
polynomials
so it's saying that if you multiply
these two polynomials and you add this
polynomial
then the result looks uniform
but i won't have possibilities to go
into details in this one but you should
look it up
what type of computation on encrypted
data is not possible or feasible
in well i would say something that
typically i would think is not possible
is
is these comparisons and
along that line evaluating
evaluating decisions decision trees it
is
it is possible but it's like
kind of slow because you have to
evaluate all possible branches
of the decision tree especially if it's
some large forest
something else that is not possible is
it's very
deep circuits um very complicated
computations where you
where you would have to do a lot of
things like
um such as neural network training
because a neural network training it
involves a computation that is like
heavily stacked it's very deep it's not
it's not the very wide circuit
that you want to evaluate it's a very
deep circuit because you need to train
repeatedly on the on the um
input data to this uh process and and
that
that is actually very difficult for
homomorphic encryption
the reason is that this noise or this
error that i mentioned already before
it grows basically proportional to the
depth of the computation that you do
this is why such very deep computations
are really hard
something that is very easy though is a
very
wide computation such as
evaluating a very high dimensional
linear model such as linear regression
even though even if there's like
millions of variables it's very easy to
do because the computation is very
shallow
but it's very wide
are there plans to add bgb scheme if not
what are some of the advantages
to using bfb or ckkks compared to
bgb there are currently no plans to add
bgv
but in fact it would be not too
difficult now
i think this is something that any of
the
open source community members could in
fact do at this point
we have maybe briefly considered it but
uh
there's no obvious advantage for us
right at this time but
there would be no obstruction to doing
that seal contains now
all of the tools for module switching
for
these levels because they are needed for
ckks
and much of the kind of challenges in
implementing ckkkks
are the same as the challenges in
implementing bgb
so actually it would be pretty easy to
implement pgp probably at this point
okay so last question
is it possible to hide access pattern
leakage in the cloud by using
homomorphic encryption
the answer to this is uh yes
but um homomorphic encryption by itself
really is not going to do that access
pattern hiding what is going to do the
access pattern hiding is that
the computation that you do for it to be
possible at all to be done on
homomorphic encryption
it has to be it can't contain any
branching
on encrypted data so
in fact this access pattern leakage
leakage hiding it comes
almost for free because because you you
just have to do it otherwise you won't
be able to even do your computation so
if you can do your computation on
encrypted data
then you know that there is no access
pattern leakage
great thank you that's all
you